c'est donc au réveil puisqu'ils étaient
à new york que le premier ministre
britannique a appris la nouvelle
la nouvelle qui avait été annoncé en fin
de matinée par les plus hauts magistrats
britannique
elle portait bien entendu sur sa
décision de suspendre les travaux du
parlement dispose pour ce nouveau volet
fait un super cochon 10 min
alors une fois réveillé le premier
ministre a réagi et voici qu'elle était
sa réaction depuis new york
si cris
alors de son côté l'opposition
travailliste réclame la démission idem
pour les libéraux-démocrates jean louis
bourlanges nouveautés carbine dans cette
affaire pour l'instant je n'arrive pas
très bien à comprendre on en est du côté
des travaillistes on a bien vu que
monsieur corps bean avait failli être
destitué outre est mise en cause en tout
cas au congrès de brighton par ses amis
mais ceux qui avaient caractérisé la
situation ces dernières semaines ce qui
était très rare pour un opposant c'est
qu'il ne demandait pas la dissolution
était violement vous êtes au pouvoir
monsieur johnson restez-y ce qui
embarrasse est profondément johnson dont
le schéma était je pars je pars en force
donc je tranche de noeud gordien mes
électeurs vont me savoir gré d'avoir
tranché le gordien je vais donc
récupérer les voix qui sont allées à
monsieur farrage et ensuite on va gagner
mais là à partir du moment où il ne peut
pas aller directement devant les
électeurs il se retrouve un peu bis
retrouvait un peu prisonnier du fait qu'
il aurait à gérer un break 6 qui sera
quand même pas papa maman pas facile pas
et que donc il va il va s'éroder
donc il est de ce qui explique que
depuis quelques jours ils cherchent
l'accord ils cherchent manifestement et
très franchement c'est faux c'est
vraiment pas normal qu'on n'arrive pas à
un accord ce bac soft faut pas exagérer
cette affaire et landaises et très
mineur par rapport à l'ensemble de
l'accord donc ils cherchent un accord
parce que là ça lui permettrait de
sortir donc tenir sur un ca de tenir
l'engagement qui a été pris et et de et
et en même temps de ne pas de ne pas
être dans une situation difficile du
coup qu'est ce qu'on va faire encore
mieux matin mais ce que l'on va
dissoudre ce que c'est réellement ce que
vous dites c'est que ça c'est important
parce que quand même vous êtes un
européen convaincu et vous pensez qu'il
faut que les européens fassent un
passage est pour qu il ya un accord avec
avec je pense que ça dépend de ce qu'on
appelle un accord mais je trouve que
l'idée c'est quand même c'est quand même
absurde la frontière qu'on va établir
entre le royaume uni et l'union
européenne ça sera pas le mur de berlin
alors l'ensemble ça sera une frontière
poreuse
il y aura très peu de contrôles s'il ya
des jeunes avaient beaucoup ça serait la
thrombose général sûr le commerce entre
le royaume-uni et le continent
donc on va avoir bon en irlande quel est
le problème
on doit on aura mon un problème de
gestion de règlement phytosanitaires
commun aux troupeaux qui valent de part
et d'autre de la frontière et irlandaise
et on pourrait très bien arriver à un
contrôle à partir des ports irlandais
c'est quand même pas très compliqué pour
un homme politique de dire qu'on ne fait
pas une frontière linéaire mais qu'on
fait des contrôles en profondeur si les
hommes politiques ne sont pas capables
de faire ça je crois qu'il faut changer
de métier avant de revenir alexis sur
justement ce qu'il faut faire avec boris
johnson sur la suite des opérations au
niveau du break site sur ce que doit
faire
johnson finalement est-ce que c'est pas
son intérêt aujourd'hui de poser sa
démission pour un an pour convoquer des
élections qui est cette femme sexy
démissionne n'y a pas d'élection il y là
il faut que des élections soient
convoquées
donc il n'a surtout pas intérêt à partir
et est la limite
cette décision de la cour suprême vu
qu'elle présente de la cour suprême elle
un peu villani stala une araignée
sur le truc demande
cette décision de la cour suprême dans
une certaine mesure en rendant la
situation encore plus compliquée et note
enfin rang dans la section son maintien
encore plus insupportable aux opposants
qui vont dire il a révoqué le parlement
et le parlement revient aux puristes et
ça peut le servir dans ce sens que ça
devrait pousser normalement encore bill
nadir bon maintenant on fait des
élections donc à la limite ça peut le
sauver lui faut surtout pas qu'ils s'en
aillent
ce que s'il s'en va il devient comme
theresa may le gars qui a calé devant le
parlement
theresa may elle a essayé de rien accord
n a pas trouvé lui l'aurait perdu dans
l'épreuve devant lui il faut qu'il reste
après soit les autres disent bernard est
est-ce qu'il ya des élections il se dit
je peux les gagner
soit il va jusqu'au bout et c'est vrai
alors là pour le coup je reviens je
rejoins sur ce que dit jean louis il ya
on a quand même l'impression qu'il ya
une double intransigeance de part et
d'autres ou pour des raisons de principe
personne ne veut faire un d'accord il
faut que chacun fasse un pas on peut pas
demander qu aux anglais de faire un pas
on va demander qu aux repas ne voit pas
pour l'instant les enfants ont dit on
veut pas bougé d'un millimètre
ça peut se justifier avant de commencer
à discuter parce qu'il faut arriver en
position de force mais quand on commence
à discuter faut que chacun fasse un pas
sinon ça pas de sens philippe il ya un
autre aspect c'est que la décision de la
cour suprême britannique est saluée
comme une victoire de la démocratie de
la défense de la démocratie
parlementaire
est-ce que derrière 7,7 cette victoire
c'est possible trion du gouvernement des
juges
non je crois pas je ne crois pas parce
que le gouvernement des juges c'est pas
une décision deux juges prise sur un cas
particulier c'est un ensemble de
décisions qu'ils se mêlent de plus en
plus dans profondeur de la vie politique
etc
non je trouve c'est très curieux jean
louis et moi on a partagé pendant des
années nos idées et notre affection avec
max gallo et max gallo avait une phrase
récurrente
il disait la seule loi de l'histoire
c'est la surprise et franchement s'est
vérifiée afin dans cette histoire-là du
brésil depuis cameron jusqu'à même
l'arrivée 2
de boris johnson au pouvoir en passant
par cette espèce de résurrection du
parlement fin de la chambre des communes
qu'on est même de la chambre des lords
d'ailleurs soyons juste qu'on
n'attendait pas on avait vraiment
l'impression que j'étais effondrée les
uns après les autres et puis tout à coup
revient c'est m
y compris d'ailleurs dans l'art oratoire
qui en dehors de jean louis bourlanges a
singulièrement déserté la tribune de
l'assemblée nationale
mais y compris dans dans la manière de
s'exprimer revient tout d'un coup une
dignité parlementaire qui me fait dire
que d'abord je suis pas tout à fait
d'accord avec ce qu'a dit alexis un
accord on l'a négocié
on a négocié la première ministre qui
précède et boris johnson n'a pas réussi
à le faire accepter par son parlement
enfin on peut pas dire que nous sommes
là à essayer de tenir ma grande bretagne
d'une manière jamais à l'abri de on veut
vraiment trop d'accord et donc quand les
autres acceptent pas il faut faire un
pas de plus soit on dit c'est pas grave
on est là sinon il existe juste juste
une chose puisque la loi de l'histoire
et la surprise est que l'une des
surprises c'est ce réveil de la chambre
des communes et de la chambre des lords
qu'est ce qui va se passer maintenant
d'initiative de la chambre des communes
qu'est-ce qu'ils vont vouloir qu'est-ce
que après cette dramatisation ce moment
dramatisation dans lequel on a pensé aux
conséquences que pourrait avoir à trois
raisons l'arrêt table au rétablissement
d'une frontière en énorme dans lequel a
été publié seront intégralement ce
rapport confidentiel sur les pénuries
les manifestations les et serra qui
risquent de suivre le la proclamation du
brésil
qu'est-ce qui se passe est ce que il est
envisageable que la chambre des communes
des sites que finalement ça serait
peut-être mieux de revenir ou de
soumettre l'accord que boris johnson va
négocier un référendum ou de revenir à
un référendum
allez savoir nicole nous dit s'ils
démissionnent cela va-t-il arranger la
situation ne s'en sort pas hébronites
audenge et y ajoute le problème majeur
c'est que corps been le leader de
l'opposition et très mal aimé il était
très mal aimés mais et si la raison pour
laquelle les travaillistes veulent pas
appelé élections ils sont quand même 10
points derrière
derrière lui se dire que si demain on
retourne aux urnes
il ya fort à parier qu'ils ressortent
renforcés et c'est le pari de johnson il
peut pas il a pas les la marge de
manoeuvre pour provoquer l'élection mais
en tout cas c'est paris que lui veut
faire
pardon mais pour l'instant les les
enquêtes d'opinion montrent que ils sont
largement 10 à 15 points au dessus des
travaillistes dans toutes les
projections et et pourquoi parce que les
travaillistes paye dans l'opinion
publique le prix d'une position très
confuse sur le bric site
on n'arrive pas à comprendre exactement
ce qu'ils veulent au point que le
recours judiciaire qui a été mené et qui
conduit à 7,7
cette décision a pas été menées par les
travaillistes mais par des gens de la
société civile dont ils ont même pas été
à la pointe de ce qui se passe
aujourd'hui donc on est parti ce qui est
très affaiblie et qui se contentent
assez bien de la situation actuelle
parce qu'il a une marge de manoeuvre à
la chambre qu'il aurait plus si on
devait repasser dans les yeux juste un
mot parce que vous disiez on ne comprend
pas pourquoi ils n'arrivent pas à
trouver un accord j'ai une hypothèse
sous m peut-être que l'europe pas
d'accord peut-être que l'europe veut
faire payer la grande bretagne
peut-être qu'il faut montrer que quand
on décide de sortir ça coûte cher parce
que si on facilite la sortie de la
grande-bretagne
c'est la porte ouverte à d'autres pays
qui vont dire finalement on peut sortir
de façon assez indolore et moi je pense
que c'est aussi ça complique la dureté
de l'europe vis-à-vis de la sortie de
son parti travailliste pour comprendre
la situation patrice est très simple
c'est les électeurs de jacques delors et
les militants de jean luc mélenchon il
faut il faut arriver à vivre avec ça bon
sur sur le plan non je ne prends pas du
tout qu'ils puissent avoir une
interprétation un peu paranoïaque un peu
complotistes cette affaire les normes et
non mais je réponds quand même parce que
ton petit ces paranoïaques
c'est ce que disent le sun c'est ce
qu'indique la seconde c'est pas du tout
vous que je mets en cause
enfin c'est une interprétation aux
complotistes la part de la presse people
britannique etc mais simplement je crois
quand même que le problème est assez
le problème est assez simple les
britanniques veulent sortir
ils veulent donc établir une frontière
entre l'union européenne et
et royaume uni et il ya un endroit où
ils disent banon là on met pas de
frontières c'est quand même
extraordinaire vous mettez vous êtes
vous installé une sécurité dans votre
maison
et alors et puis vous dites là il ya la
porte de service
il n'y aura pas de sécurité donc c'était
évidemment une situation où ils sont
dans une situation absurde c'est pour ça
je crois en revanche que c'est en compte
tenu de la nature des relations qui
s'établiront entre le royaume-uni et le
continent et y resteront assez fluide
je crois qu'on doit trouver une solution
je le dis c'est vrai que actuellement
vous pouvez pas mettre une frontière au
milieu de la république au milieu de
l'irlande il ya ça ne résiste pas une
caméra explose dans les deux minutes qui
suivent une solution oui irlandais n'est
pas question pour les républicains
irlandais de tolérer la moindre
frontière donc le gouvernement dira ne
le fera pas
qui ferait cette frontière au sable
d'irlande de personnes
les irlandais ne le font pas alors on va
envoyer des contingents hongrois ou ou
français d'un bain dans le cadre de deux
des systèmes communautaires non alors
donc il met en revanche regarder comment
c'est fait comment ça se fait l'angle le
commerce entre l'irlande et le continent
c'est yayale de trois ports de porc
essentiellement belfast et dublin
et puis voilà et on peut on peut trouver
si on fait preuve de mai quelque chose
qu'il faut dire aux repas parce que
c'est la solution que vous dessinez les
propres exit britanniques se seraient
c'est pour autre chose qu on vit rsa
c'est l'europe qui veut ma à la chasse
est vrai que je ne vaux pas ce truc là
parce que ça n'a pas voté ça n'a pas été
vraiment posé ce qu'a fait
c'est un peu facile de dire c'est drôle
c'est quand même difficile entre dublin
et l'union européenne de même que c'est
difficile pour les voter donc il faut il
faut effectivement mesures et les
inconvénients de deh cho dans l'essai
dérogatoire en principe il doit y avoir
une frontière ils n'en veulent pas on
est vraiment en englobant tout le monde
sait que c'est impossible parce que même
les européens savent que cette frontière
au windows 7 apparaît que c'est à dire
une version 10 0 leur est acquise en
rapport avec un nom il faudrait que ça
c'est les britanniques devaient pas
sortir c'est tout ces appartements ils
ont besoin de maintenir la veut saisir
toute espèce de prétexte de la
réunification
donc ils ne veulent absolument pas
entendre parler d'aucune des solutions
dangereux a parlé ni alexis parce que
c'est une position pire mais savent bien
que c'est matériellement possible mais
ils ne veulent pas en entendre parler
parce que si on parle de quelque chose
qui concerne le der land du nord ça nous
a pénalisés cc doivent au contraire ils
veulent même la réunifier les
britanniques veulent pas diviser royaume
uni et les irlandais ne veulent pas
diviser l'irlande on pas quand même chez
les brouiller et les nationalistes
écossais pousse au crime pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de blessés voilà on peut se
débrouiller ou pas c'est insoluble
estime nicole puisque lieu ne veut pas
accepter le plan du bric site et que les
britanniques ne change rien non plus
c'est la question sur la mairie de paris
mais c'est moins compliqué que les
élections à la mairie de paris on en
débattra
sur pas ce soir mais c'est effectivement
un sujet qui est sur la table
le spectacle continue demain à 11h30
heure de londres la réouverture de la
chambre des communes en tous les cas
c'est ce qu'a promis le speaker john
bercow et qui n'a pas démissionné
apparemment il a gardé ses cravates
bariolées illégal je le fais dans la
feuille blanche
exactement et la suite ce sera également
le discours de politique générale de la
reine le 14 octobre
on continuera d'en parler